voilà à quoi ressemble laboratoires de
recherche dans une université
nous sommes sur le campus de schoelcher
prescilla à 23 ans christophe 24 ans
tous deux licenciés et leur biologie lui
en physique chimie
ils ressemblent à deux jeunes qui font
des expériences et pourtant ils viennent
de réussir un bel exploit avant la fin
de leurs études
transformer les sargasses en une
solution solide pour faire du carton ou
du bois
mais avant le résultat final les
sargasses subissent des traitements
chimiques
à la fin nous obtenons cette poule qui
en la modifiant nous donnera notre
carton on va ajouter de l'eau et
d'autres substances à obtenir cette
sorte de bête ça nous allons rajouter
quelques fibres végétales et obtenir du
coton bio à moindre coût qui nous
permettra de fabriquer des boîtes
ça peut être des planches des solides
pas solide
on peut faire tous types de matériaux
cartonné avec et voilà ce biomatériaux
carte onu qui deviendrait une planche ou
du carton mais il faut savoir que dans
d'autres pays
la recherche pour transformer les
sargasses avance et vite
vous avez très certainement pas su cette
vidéo sur votre téléphone portable
nous sommes au mexique les axes sont
transformés en prix qu'en feuille de
papier ou en chaussures une économie à
grande échelle
[Musique]
retour dans notre labo à schoelcher nous
deux étudiants chercheurs ne sont pas
que des scientifiques
ils ont le sens des affaires ils ont
monté une start up pour commercialiser
leurs trouvailles the marine boxe nous
avons estimé qu'il s'agit de concepts
innovants qui permettrait d'utiliser les
sargasses et de développer l'économie
locale
donc grâce à cela on ça pourrait pallier
les risques et les contraintes qui sont
liées aux sagas sur le plan économique
sanitaire et écologique donc grâce à ces
startups nous pouvons rebâtir et enlever
les halles qui sont présents sur nos
côtes et qui s'amassent au fil du temps
pour que les aider dans leurs recherches
une équipe de chercheurs ils sont prêts
à accueillir toutes les entreprises
toutes les personnes qui ont des idées
des projets qui intéresse notre
environnement nous nevers effectivement
à toutes les sociétés ou en devenir ou
existantes convocation effectivement à à
se développer ou qui ont simplement des
idées on essaye de faire en sorte
effectivement qu'elle aboutisse nous
étudiants sont encore à la recherche de
laminoirs pour aplatir leurs pattes la
sargasse et en faire des planches
ils présenteront également leurs projets
en septembre prochain dans le cadre de
concours lancé par l' agence nationale
de recherche et dans quelques mois vous
utiliserez peut-être que des boîtes à
base de sargasses mais d'une martinique